un grand merci tout d'abord à tous les
intervenants de la matinée pour la
qualité de leurs questions la pertinence
de leurs
réponses nous vous avions promis un
conseil national consacré à notre projet
d'alternance vous êtes servi et ce n'est
pas fini en effet cet après-midi vous
aurez le bonheur avec nous d'écouter
Eric vert Laurent vquier Luc Chatel
François Fillon et bien évidemment notre
président c
SAR en effet il le dit souvent le
premier parti de France se devait de
travailler à des propositions crédibles
car il est très
attendu les Français sont en effet
fatigués quand ils ne sont pas colère
après ce président de la République dont
l'absence de vision n'a d'égale que son
insupportable cynisme ils sont chaudés
ces Français par ces ministres qui
disent mais qui ne font pas toute
ressemblance avec d'actuel membres du
gouvernement serait purement porcite ou
pire par ce premier ministre incapable
de convaincre sa propre majorité de
voter un texte qui prétend rien de moins
que moderniser le droit du travail je
veux parler de cette loi que nous
examinerons chers collègues députés en
deè lecture à l'Assemblée nationale à
compté de mardi prochain une loi qui
restera dans la petite
pour ce qu'elle a généré en
manifestation blocage et autres exs
plutôt que pour ce qu'elle aura apporté
à l'emploi et à la croissance alors si
les Français n'en peuvent plus et on
peut les comprendre et bien je veux leur
dire que nous non plus avouons que rien
ne nous aura été épargné ces qure
dernières années augmentation sans
précédent du chômage des impôts de la
pauvreté désorganisation totale de
l'organisation territoriale de la
République perte de l'autorité de l'État
et absence coupable de la voie de notre
pays à l'international comme au niveau
européen ça fait beaucoup et ça suffit
et à la question S ou encore avec une
grande majorité de français nous les
républicains nous disons stop et nous
nous mettons en ordre de marche quel
chemin parcouru en seulement un an et
demi nous avons changé de nom nous nous
appelons les républicains ce nom nous
oblige nous portons les valeurs de
liberté d'égalité et de fraternité ça a
été dit ce matin la France ne doit rien
céder sur ses valeurs nous avons le
devoir de les faire vivre au quotidien
nous avons renoué avec les adhérents les
républicains sont la première force
politique avec plus de 300000 adhérents
nous avons enregistré des victoires à
toutes les élections et oui
être le premier parti de France c'est
bien mais c'est encore mieux quand les
candidats qui portent nos couleurs
fièrement gagnent les élections depuis
2012 nous avons remporté 18 élections
législatives partielles sur 22 nous
sommes à la tête de 60 % des
départements et de 8 régions sur 13 si
la France ne va pas mieux nous si les
comptes se redressent grâce à la
détermination toute diplomatique de
notre trésorier national Daniel Fasquel
notre politique a bâti son projet
d'alternance grâce au travail énorme et
sans relâche d'ériic vert notre délégué
général au projet et enfin la commission
d'investiture a investit 90 % de nos
candidats aux élections législative de
2017 alors oui chers amis nous les
républicains nous avons mis à profit ces
derniers mois pour
travailler à la réaffirmation de nos
valeurs vous avez tous pu débattre dans
les fédérations sur le texte
d'orientation
que le président Nicolas sarzi nous a
soumis le 14 février dernier c'était
l'ordre de notre dernier conseil
national à la productiontion de nos
propositions vous avez pu vous exprimer
après chaque réunion de travail
thématique vous avez été des milliers à
répondre à chaque fois et aujourd'hui
vous allez pouvoir voter sur ce projet
personnellement je voterai pour à la
hiérarchisation de nos priorités enfin
vous avez travaillé et les référents
territoriaux que tuumé au bureau de ce
Conseil national cher Luc se sont pliés
à l'exercice chez nous vous l'avez
peut-être fait chez vous en î les
Villaines nous l'avons fait et tu nous a
interrogé cher Luc sur nos
priorités que retiennent-ils comme thème
prioritaire chez nous en î vilen et donc
en Bretagne dans l'ordre
l'emploi sachant que le chômage reste la
première des inégalités sociales dans
notre pays la dépense publique et la
fiscalité l'immigration et la sécurité
enfin l'éducation cher Annie sur tous
ces thèmes nous les républicains
apportons des réponses sérieuses mais
nous devons aller plus loin et répondre
collectivement aux trois questions qui
nous ont été posées pas plus tard que ce
mercredi au cours de la réunion sur les
institutions que veut-on faire c'est la
question du sens que l'on donne à notre
action qui va le faire c'est la question
de l'équipe qui va la mettre en œuvre
comment va-t-on le faire c'est la
question de l'organisation et des moyens
qui vont être mis en place dans moins de
5 mois nous nous serons choisis un
candidat à l'issue des primaires
ouvertes ouvertes de la droite et du
centre dès le 28 novembre nous serons
tous tous des soutiens actifs de notre
héros avec un
H d'ici la présidentielle de
2017 ne doute pas que notre famille
politique rassemblée aura convaincu sur
son projet sur son équipe et sur les
moyens mais pour cela nous avons besoin
de vous et pour cela vous pouvez compter
sur nous je vous
remercie